we're making a biopic about Richard
montanez's life I got an idea it's a
spicy Camp it's gonna change everything
this man is responsible for the success
of the flaming hot Cheeto and this huge
Global brand and we need to know that
new products do not get created by Blue
Collar hoodlums who probably can't spell
the word hoodlum it's not just being the
underdog or a rags to Rich's story this
is a story about when people
underestimate you not only as a person
as a community
don't get shots like this so don't blow
it and so to be able to explore our
community through his lens has been a
blessing see the Hispanic market will
not be ignored the Hispanic market will
not be ignored good but in your voice
this has been the best filming
experience of my life because of what
we're shooting the story that we're
telling is so important I'm Mexican and
we spend money on snacks just like
everybody else as a Mexican-American I
didn't even know the story and I was
like oh my God this is such an inspiring
story to be reflected back on the big
screen he was a warrior man she's just a
force there's no way this movie could
have been made without her
typically
[Music]
I want Paving away as a director and a
producer I mean working with Eva it's
been a dream everybody read the script
and said oh my God I need to do this
film and that's why I wanted to surround
myself with people who had the same
energy and passion as I did to make a
very special film that has never been
done before there's this whole Market
that no one else is paying attention to
us this story resonated with me because
his story is my story having the
discipline and desire to not have more
be more and I think everybody is going
to say there's a piece of me that is
reflected on the screen and in this
story
thank you
[Music]